♪ ♪
>> Greg: HAPPY WEDNESDAY,
EVERYBODY!
SO, PRESIDENT BIDEN IS IN DEEP
TROUBLE.
THE WHITE HOUSE REPORTS HE'S
TESTING NEGATIVE FOR COVID,
WHICH PROVES EVEN THE VIRUS
WANTS SOMEONE ELSE.
[SCATTERED LAUGHTER]
ACCORDING TO A NEW CNN POLL,
OVER THREE QUARTERS OF
RESPONDENTS DON'T WANT HIM TO
RUN FOR PRESIDENT.
THEY WANT HIM TO RUN FOR THE
HILLS.
THE POLL COMES AS HIS APPROVAL
RATINGS PLUNGE LIKE
NANCY PELOSI'S NECKLINE.
AND MOST AMERICANS ARE AS
DISGUSTED WITH THE ECONOMY AS
THEY ARE WITH NANCY PELOSI'S
NECKLINE.
[SCATTERED LAUGHTER]
OF COURSE THERE IS NO RECESSION,
THEY SAY, AS THEY TRY TO
REDEFINE THE TERM RECESSION THE
WEIGHT THEY REDEFINED RIOTS AND
WOMEN AND CRIME IN BASIC
BIOLOGY.
WE WOULD SAY THAT LIFE TAKES
SOME BALLS, BUT WE DON'T WANT TO
MISS GENDER IT.
IT'S GETTING SO BAD, MAYOR PETE
IS POLLING BETTER THAN JOE AND
PETE HAS ACTUALLY DONE LESS WORK
ON THE JOB THEN KAMALA HAS ON
CLOSING THE BORDER.
PETE IS NOW IN HIS TENTH MONTH
OF PARENTAL LEAVE AND WILL BE
READY TO WORK FULL TIME ONCE HE
STOPPED LACTATING.
BUT I GET IT, JOE DOES NOT LOOK
GOOD, LITERALLY AND ACCURATELY.
THE ONLY THING HOLDING THEM
TOGETHER IS THAT HER PLUGS.
AND YOU CAN SEE WHY.
HERE IS A 22ND CLIP COMING FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE, LOOK AT HOW
MUCH IT WAS EDITED.
>> President Biden: THIS LAW
DOES SO MUCH MORE.
IT SAVES LIVES, INCLUDING YOURS.
IT WILL HELP YOU DO YOUR JOB,
BUT IT'S JUST A START.
LAST WEEK I ROLLED OUT MY SAFE
AMERICA PLAN WITH THE GOAL OF
DOING THREE KEY THINGS.
FIRST, TAKE ADDITIONAL
COMMON SENSE STEPS TO REDUCE GUN
CRIMES AND VIOLENCE.
>> Greg: THEY SPENT MORE TIME
EDITING THAT 20 SECOND CLIP AND
COPPOLA DID TO BOTH "GODFATHER."
THE LIST FOR DR. FRANKENSTEIN
THE COMIC PIECE TOGETHER HIS
MONSTER HE PUT IN A BRAIN.
IF YOU HAVE TO DO THAT MUCH
SURGERY FOR 20 SECONDS OF TAPE,
THAT'S LIKE STARTING WITH A
6-TON PIECE OF MARBLE AND ENDING
UP WITH A BOWLING TROPHY.
IF THE CREEPIEST PRESIDENTIAL
CLIP SINCE THE FILM.
[SCATTERED LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: ALL, DID I UPSET YOU?
>> DARK.
>> Greg: I'M SORRY.
>> DARK HUMOR TODAY.
>> Greg: TAKE A LOOK AT THIS
COMPARISON ON TWITTER, WHERE I
GET ALL MY RESEARCH.
IT WORKS FOR
"THE WASHINGTON POST."
IT SHOWS TWO DIFFERENT BIDENS
APPARENTLY 24 HOURS APART.
>> President Biden: AS WE
FIGHT INFLATION, YOU CAN'T BE
PRO-INSURRECTION AND PRO-COP.
RUNNING DOWN GAS PRICES IS A BIG
PART OF THE JOB.
YOU CAN'T BE PRO-INSURRECTION
AND PRO-DEMOCRACY.
AND PRO-AMERICAN.
HERE'S THE GOOD NEWS, GAS PRICES
ARE DROPPED EVERY DAY THIS
SUMMER.
THAT'S MORE THAN 40 DAYS IN A
ROW.
DONALD TRUMP LACKED THE COURAGE
TO ACT.
WE NOW HAVE 40,000 GAS STATIONS
IN THE UNITED STATES WHERE THE
PRESS OF GAS IS $3.99 OR LESS.
THE BRAVE WOMAN AND MEN IN BLUE
ALL ACROSS THIS NATION SHOULD
NEVER FORGET THAT.
>> Greg: WOW.
WHAT THE HELL IS GOING ON?
I MEAN, THAT'S THE SAME GUY.
THEY ARE AS DIFFERENT -- ONE
MINUTE HE'S FINE, THE NEXT HE
HAS THE DELIVERY YOU'D EXPECT
FROM A P.O.W. VIDEO.
THEY SHOULD HAVE HIM HOLD UP A
COPY OF "USA TODAY" SO WE HAVE
PROOF OF LIFE.
WHAT'S GOING ON, JOE?
>> I'M NOT WORKING HARD, I'M
HARDWORKING.
>> ARE NOT JUST A PROFESSOR,
POLITICAL PHILOSOPHY AT PENN.
>> LET ME TELL YOU SOMETHING,
THAT'S ALL A BUNCH OF --
POPPY SEED BAGELS.
SINCE MY WIFE, RIGHT?
SHE'S A DOCTOR.
>> I SAID IT MY CREAM OF WHEAT
THIS MORNING.
♪ ♪
[APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: NO WONDER THE DEMS
WANT TO DITCH JOE FASTER THAN A
MASSEUSE WITH ROUGH HANDS AND
MONKEYPOX.
THE GUY IS DETERIORATING FASTER
THAN JOY BEHAR'S MOOD WHEN SHE
RUNS OUT OF PIE.
MAYBE IT'S COVID THAT'S MESSING
JOE UP, BUT IT'S NOT LIKE WE
WERE BLESSED WITH A FIT
SPECIMEN.
IF THE GUY STARTED OUT BAD, NOW
HE'S WORSE.
I MEAN, EVEN HIS BODY DOUBLE
LOOKS EXHAUSTED.
I HOPE FOR THE SAKE OF AMERICA
AND THE PLANET HE'S OKAY,
BECAUSE IF HE'S NOT, THIS IS
WHAT WE GOT.
>> [LAUGHS]
>> Greg: YEAH, IT SUCKS.
IT SEEMS THE PRESS STILL SEEMS
MORE CONSUMED BY THE PAST,
MEANING DONALD TRUMP.
THEN I GET IT.
IT'S THE OLD HEY, DON'T LOOK
THERE, LOOK OVER YOUR TRIP, BUT
AT LEAST TRUNK AND COMPLETE
SENTENCES, HAS IDEAS ABOUT CRIME
AND HOMELESSNESS, AND ISN'T KEPT
CHAINED TO A RADIATOR SOMEWHERE
IN THE WEST WING BEING FORCE FED
ADDERALL IN HIS OATMEAL.
YOU KNOW, I WONDER WHAT WOULD
TRUMP DO IF HE WERE A BASKETBALL
COACH OF THE WOMEN'S TEAM?
WILL HE EVER LOSE?
>> IF I WERE A BASKETBALL COACH
OF A WOMAN'S TEAM, I WOULD
NEVER EVER LOSE, I BE THE
GREATEST COACH OF ALL TIME.
I'M NOT A FAN OF LeBRON JAMES
AT ALL.
LeBRON, DID YOU EVER THINK OF
BECOMING A WOMAN?
BECAUSE I'D LIKE THE HEAVY ON ON
MY TEAM.
WE LOOK AT THE TENTS OF THE
HOMELESS AND YOU SAY WHAT'S
HAPPENING TO THIS GREAT BASTION?
CREATE THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS
OF HIGH QUALITY TENTS WHICH CAN
BE DONE IN ONE DAY.
ONE DAY.
YOU HAVE TO MOVE PEOPLE OUT, THE
ONES THAT DON'T HAVE A DRUG
PROBLEM ARE THOSE THAT INSTITUTE
A VERY QUICK TRIAL, DEATH
PENALTY SENTENCE, OR
DRUG DEALERS.
>> Greg: IT'S GOOD TO SEE HE
HASN'T CHANGED.
HE STILL HAS THE SUBTLETY AND
RESTRAINT YOU'D EXPECT FROM A
MAN WITH HIS NAME ON BUILDINGS,
GOLF COURSES, AND STAKES.
ANY STEAK WITH THE NAME BIDEN ON
IT WOULD COME PUREED IN A
SQUEEZE TUBE.
BUT THE DEMS NEED HELP, RIGHT?
MAYBE THEY'RE NOT LOOKING HARD
ENOUGH.
BUT YOU KNOW, I THINK I CAN
HELP.
I THINK I HAVE THEIR CANDIDATE.
THIS GUY, JOHN HINCKLEY.
YEAH, HE'S OUT OF JAIL NOW.
AND HERE'S WHAT HE JUST TWEETED.
I BELIEVE IN PEACE, LOVE,
EQUITY, LGBTQ WRITES,
ABORTION-RIGHTS, ANIMAL RIGHTS,
RACE MIXING, ASSAULT WEAPON BAN,
SHARING THE WEALTH,
GREEN NEW DEAL, BLACK LIVES
MATTER, PRISON REFORM, AND GOOD
ROCK 'N' ROLL.
JOHN.
JOIN THE JOHN HIGLEY COMMUNITY.
YEAH, IT'S LOOK AT THE CORNER OF
[BLEEP] CRAZY BOULEVARD AND A
WHOLE AVENUE.
BUT HE'S NOT HERE NOW AND WHEN
HE SHOT REAGAN, MEANING HE
SOUNDS LIKE THE PERFECT WOKE
DEMOCRAT.
ARE YOU SURE THAT ISN'T AOC IN
THE BATMAN SUIT?
HE TICKED EVERY BOX!
ALTHOUGH ODDLY HE DID FORGET
HANDGUNS.
BUT I GUESS THEY MUST HAVE HAD
CNN ON THE PRISON TV, BECAUSE HE
SOUNDS NO DIFFERENT THAN
DON LEMON.
AND THAT IS CNN'S WAITING
STRATEGY, SHOW IT WHERE YOU
CAN'T CHANGE THE CHANNEL.
TALK ABOUT CRUEL AND UNUSUAL
PUNISHMENT.
THAT'S LIKE TELLING A GUY ON
DEATH ROW TO SHARE HIS LAST MEAL
WITH BRIAN STELTER.
BUT THIS LOSER ILLUSTRATES A KEY
POINT THESE DAYS.
YOU WANT THE PRESS AND THE LIBS
TO LIKE YOU, JUST TOTAL WOKE
LINE AND ANYONE CAN DO IT.
EVEN A FAILED ASSASSIN WITH AN
ACOUSTIC GUITAR AND A FACE LIKE
A LUMPY POTATO.
HINCKLEY IS LIVING HIS BEST LIFE
BUT I DON'T WANT TO BE AROUND
WHEN HE HEARS THE NEWS THAT
JODIE FOSTER IS GAY.
SO THERE YOU GO, DEMOCRATS, YOU
WANTED A BIG NAME, YOU GOT ONE,
A CELEB WHO APPEALS TO ALL OF
YOUR LITTLE IDENTITY CULTS, AND
HE CAN SING.
♪ ♪
>> ♪♪ THERE IS SO MUCH ANGER IN
THE WORLD ♪
♪ I WANT TO SEE SOME LOVE ♪
♪ EVERYBODY SEEMS TO BE SUCH A
WORLD ♪
♪ I WANT TO SEE SOME LOVE ♪♪
>> Greg: HE'S NO CAT STEVENS.
CLOSER TO CAT FOOD.
BUT HE SURE BEATS THIS.
>> [LAUGHS]
>> OKAY.
>> DREAM BIG!
FIGHT HARD, AND LET'S WIN!
>> Greg: AND LET'S NOT FORGET
THIS GUY.
♪ ♪
THAT'S A REFERENCE.
SO WHAT DO YOU THINK, DEMOCRATS?
HINCKLEY 2024?
HE CAN'T BE THAT MUCH WORSE THAN
WHAT YOU'VE GOT.
HIS CAMPAIGN SLOGAN COULD BE
"GIVE ME A SHOT."
I JUST MIGHT BLOW YOU AWAY.
♪ ♪
WHAT'S WELCOME TO MAKE GUESTS!
HIS LAST JOB AS A MANNEQUIN FOR
J.CREW, HOST OF THE GUY BENCH
AND SHOW, GUY BENSON
!
HE SIGNED WITH THE NFL, PLAYED
SUPERMAN ON TV, AND DATA BROOKE
SHIELDS, BUT OTHER THAN THAT
HE'S DONE NOTHING IMPRESSIVE.
ACTOR AND PRODUCER, DEAN CAIN!
[SCATTERED APPLAUSE]
SHE'S LIKE THE GIRL NEXT DOOR IF
YOU LIVE NEXT TO WOMEN'S PRISON,
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF!
AND FINALLY, HIS FOOTPRINT HAS
THREE TIME ZONES, MY MASSIVE
SIDEKICK AND THE NWA WORLD
TELEVISION CHAMPION, TYRUS!
[APPLAUSE]
THAT WAS A VERY DARK MONOLOGUE.
>> IT'S GUY TOWN AGAIN, I KNOW
HOW MUCH YOU LOVE ALL THE GUY
TOWN -- I WHAT ONE
>> Greg: LET'S SEE IT.
>> DEPRESSING ALL Y'ALL'S
FEELINGS YOU'RE SCARED TO CRY
AND YOUR DAD WAS MEAN!
TALKING TO YOUR DOGS ABOUT YOUR
PROBLEM, PEOPLE JUDGE YOU.
WE LIVE IN A WORLD WHERE MEN
CAN'T EXPRESS THEMSELVES!
[SCATTERED APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: I DON'T LIKE THAT
ONE.
I FELT LIKE I WAS ATTACKED.
BUT IT'S TRUE, WE HAVE GUYS HERE
TONIGHT, ONE OF MY FAVORITE
GUYS, DEAN CAIN.
SO HOW ARE YOU DOING?
>> I'M DOING GREAT.
FIRST OF ALL, GRADUATIONS TO YOU
CRUSHING LATE NIGHT.
>> Greg: THANK YOU.
[SCATTERED APPLAUSE]
>> I LIVE IN THAT BASTION OF
WOKENESS CALLED HOLLYWOOD AND TO
SEE YOU ON TOP, REALLY,
REALLY --
>> Greg: AND THEY DON'T TALK
ABOUT THE SHOW.
>> NEVER VARIED
>> Greg: THEY CAN'T TALK ABOUT
IT BECAUSE IT'S TOO HUMILIATING.
>> I'LL TALK ABOUT IT.
>> Greg: YOU ARE SUPERMAN.
>> NOT ANYMORE.
>> Greg: HERE'S A QUESTION,
WHAT'S IN WORSE CONDITION, JOE
OR HIS PARTY?
IT'S KIND OF TOUGH.
>> I WOULD SAY JOE.
I MEAN, LOOKING AT THAT VIDEO,
THAT VIDEO, WHICH WAS EDITED --
I THINK YOUR ACCOUNTING FOR FIVE
TIMES, IT WAS EVERY SENTENCE.
IF THAT WAS, SCARY STUFF.
I'VE NOTICED ON TWITTER IS
THEY'VE MADE IT VERY CLEAR
DURING THAT ONE VERY, VERY
FROGGY-VOICED BIT, HE NEVER
BLINKS.
>> Greg: YEAH, HE NEVER
POINTS.
>> IT IS A HOSTAGE VIDEO.
IT IS.
IT'S SCARY TO ME.
I WISH IT WEREN'T THE CASE, IT'S
ACTUALLY SEPARATE COUNTRY THAT
THAT'S THE GUY LEADING IT,
BUT --
>> Greg: WHEN YOU HAVE --
WHO'S IN THE DUGOUT ON DECK, A
LITTLE BASEBALL PHRASE THERE.
VERY LITTLE.
>> AND THAT LAUGH, I JUST CAN'T.
IT DOES THINGS TO THE BACK OF MY
NECK.
>> Greg: [CACKLES]
GUY, WHAT IS YOUR PREDICTION FOR
2024?
WELCOME TO THE SHOW, I'M GLAD
YOU SHAVE YOUR BEARD.
>> YOU ASKED ME TO.
YOUR SHOW, IF LEAVING RASH.
I BET YOU THE WHITE HOUSE --
>> YEAH.
>> THIS IS LONG-ESTABLISHED.
THIS IS LONG-ESTABLISHED, NOT
EVEN NEWS ANYMORE.
I'M WAITING FOR THE WHITE HOUSE
TO COME OUT AND TELL US THAT WAS
ALL SHOT IN ONE TAKE.
BECAUSE THEY WILL BE LIKE WE'RE
JUST REDEFINING ONE TAKE.
SO THAT'S WHAT IT WAS.
THAT'S WHAT THEY WOULD DO.
CAN I COMMENT BRIEFLY ON JOHN
HIGLEY?
I'M STILL HUNG UP ON THAT PART
OF THE MONOLOGUE.
>> Greg: ISN'T THAT CRAZY?
>> THIS IS MAYBE A BIT OF A
CONTROVERSIAL OPINION, BUT I
BELIEVE THAT IF YOU ATTEMPT TO
ASSASSINATE A PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, I'M OKAY WITH YOU
BEING CANCELED FOREVER.
I'M NOT IN FAVOR OF
CANCEL CULTURE, BUT FOR THAT
TYPE OF PERSON, YES.
AND JUST IF YOU LOOK YOU CAN GET
BACK IN THE GOOD GRACES OF
POLITE SOCIETY FOR JUST VOMITING
EVERY WOKE PLATITUDE IS PROBABLY
NOT A DUMB MOVE ON HIS PART.
IT WILL PROBABLY WORK TO SOME
EXTENT, BUT I'M IN FAVOR IN THIS
ONE INSTANCE OF CANCEL CULTURE.
IT'S A HIGH BAR, BUT HE MET IT.
>> Greg: HE HAD A CONCERT IN
BROOKLYN.
HE ACTUALLY WAS ABLE TO GET A
GIG.
>> SOLD OUT.
>> Greg: SOLD OUT BUT THEN
AFTER AN OUTCRY HE CANCELED IT.
SO IT WAS CANCELED.
BECAUSE THERE YOU GO, I SUPPORT
THAT ONE CANCELLATION.
>> Greg: THERE YOU GO.
YOU ARE A LITTLE BIT WOKE.
BUT YOU'RE RIGHT, HE KNEW WHAT
TO DO.
IT WAS TOTALLY CALCULATED,
TYRUS.
HE HAD EVERYTHING IN THERE.
>> HE WAS MISSING THE UKRAINE
FLAG.
>> I WAS TAKEN ABACK AND KIND OF
SHOCKED.
I DIDN'T KNOW THAT RACE MIXING
WAS A BAD THING ALL OF A SUDDEN.
I DIDN'T KNOW THAT WAS ON THE
DOCKET SOMEWHERE.
OF PEOPLE WERE UP IN ARMS ABOUT
ALL THIS RACE MIXING GOING ON.
>> Greg: WHO EVEN USES THAT
PHRASE?
>> I DIDN'T KNOW --
>> HE WAS IN PRISON FOR DECADES!
HE DIDN'T KNOW!
>> IT IS STILL 1978 FOR HIM
>> RACE MIXING.
[LAUGHS]
WHAT HAPPENS TO THE KNOW RACE
MIXING?
>> Greg: THAT WOULD BE GREAT,
HIM COMING OUT AND WANTING
THINGS TO BE LEGAL THAT ARE
LEGAL.
>> LIKE WHAT?
AND HERE'S THE DEAL.
THIS IS -- HEY, THIS IS WHERE
PROGRESSIVE WOKE BITES YOU A
LITTLE BIT.
I'M JUST CURIOUS OF THE EDITOR,
WHAT GROUP THEY WERE
REPRESENTING THE FIRST OF, HOW
WE ARE GOING TO EDIT FILMS,
BECAUSE I'M PRETTY SURE MY
8-YEAR-OLD DRUNK COULD EDIT
BETTER THAN THAT.
THAT WAS EITHER INTENTIONAL LIKE
WE GOT TO GET RID OF THIS GUY --
BECAUSE THEY WEREN'T EVEN THE
SAME SHOT.
IT WAS CLOSE UP, BACK AWAY,
CLOSE UP -- THEY ARE LITERALLY
TELLING YOU THIS GUY CAN'T
COMPLETE A SENTENCE.
IT WAS LIKE THERE HOSTAGE KNOW
TO THE REST OF US, LIKE HE CAN'T
EVEN GET THROUGH A SENTENCE.
>> Greg: IT WAS --
>> THAT EDITOR, SOMEONE IS TO BE
WATCHING OUT FOR THEM UNLESS
THEY WERE RACE MIXERS.
>> Greg: DID YOUR HEARTBEAT A
LITTLE BIT WHEN YOU WERE
LISTENING TO TRUMP LIKE OH, MY
GOD, I MISSED THAT -- I MISS THE
UNIQUE IDEAS!
I JUST SORT OF LAUGHING ABOUT
LeBRON JAMES, IT WAS KILLING
ME.
>> JUST THE FACT WE ARE HEARING
A PRESIDENT WHO CAN HAVE A
COMPLETE SENTENCE AND SHIFT A
TRAIN OF THOUGHT IS KIND OF
COOL.
>> ON PURPOSE!
SKIP A TRAIN OF THOUGHT ON
PURPOSE.
>> AND WHAT HE SAYS I DON'T KNOW
WE KNOW HE'S BEING SARCASTIC.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU CAN -- WHEN
HE SAYS IT IF LIKE HE DOESN'T
KNOW.
>> Greg: KAT, WHAT YOU THINK
ABOUT HINCKLEY 2024?
WOULD YOU SUPPORT?
>> I THINK HE ACTUALLY MIGHT
HAVE A SHOT.
NOT IN A PUN WAY.
WHEN I SAW THE RUNDOWN FOR THIS
TODAY, I GOOGLED JOHN HINCKLEY.
I WOULD LIKE THERE'S NO WAY -- I
THOUGHT I WAS HAVING A STROKE
BECAUSE I THOUGHT -- I WAS
CERTAIN I KNEW THIS WAS.
I WAS LIKE IT COULDN'T BE THAT
SAME GUY IF THIS IS WHAT'S
HAPPENING.
BUT IT WAS.
SO MAYBE THAT COULD HAPPEN ON A
LARGER SCALE WHERE PEOPLE WILL
BE LIKE OH, IT COULDN'T POSSIBLY
BE THAT JOHN HINCKLEY AND I JUST
VOTE FOR HIM.
>> Greg: I THINK I MIGHT BE
THE ONLY PERSON WHO SUGGESTS
THIS AS AN IDEA BUT IT WAS BASED
ON THAT TWEET, THAT JUST
COMPLETELY -- IT WAS SO BRAZENLY
VIRTUE SIGNALING, YOU KNOW?
>> HE HAS NO SHOT IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY THOUGH
BECAUSE HE'S APPARENTLY A
STRAIGHT WHITE DUDE WITH A
GUITAR, THE WHITEST NAME EVER.
>> BUT IF HE COMES OUT AS
NONBINARY.
>> IF YOU RUNS WITH THE JUICE.